good afternoon so quiz number three is
up there's still some people who haven't
taken one or two take it it's for your
own good and those listening take it
please and I would probably you all here
have completed it but the people not
quizzes second thing friends day dr.
Silverstein will be lecturing I will not
be here he's not the greatest with the
equipment it has happened that
recordings have not been made although
this time I am sure it will work right
you wouldn't lay bet on okay just a
warning you might want to come to
Wednesday's he will also be lecturing a
week from Wednesday I will be back by
then and make sure it works so you will
miss one at the most right but I'm going
to teach him how to do it today and last
year he missed one so just a warning
okay anything else okay lights we got
lights I want to go over some slides
from last time which I didn't get a
chance to get to take the lights down
for this now you remember I told you the
movie of flu exploding wasn't right I
just want to show you a still from the
movie to show you why ok these are two
captures here's one alright so start on
the bottom they have this image with an
envelope around the capsid is that right
for influenza virus no what is she's
shaking your head no no it's not right
the influenza RNA is wrapped up in a
helical nucleocapsid not a capsid like
this so this is wrong and then when it
comes apart you see there triangles here
if you see a triangle what do you think
of icosahedron right this is not an
icosahedron so this is wrong the
artist's rendition is incorrect okay so
that's that remember flu is an envelope
virus with a nucleo capsid HeLa CLIA
arranged and it does have a protein
around it that forms a shell but it's
not called the cap
that's just the M protein which has a
variety of other functions okay so
that's what's wrong with the movie then
we didn't finish at the end of last time
I just want to quickly go through a few
slides one was to show you an example of
a virus that uses two two receptors to
attach to cells and I wanted to go
through this because maybe you're
thinking why would a virus need two
receptors shouldn't one be enough and in
theory yes because a lot of viruses in
fact use just one receptor but Coxsackie
Group B viruses need two one is called
DAF and the other is called car these
viruses initiate infection at the
epithelial surface like this but the
problem here is that car one of the two
receptors is a component of tight
junctions which are right here next to
cells not at the top so these receptors
are not on the top of the cell so how
does the virus infect the the mechanism
is very interesting and it's elucidated
by this experiment I just want to show
you this because it's very neat so these
are cells polarized cells which means
they have a top and a bottom growing in
a plastic dish and they've infected them
with coxsackievirus and then they're
using antibodies to look at where the
virus is and where car is and where DAF
is so the virus and the two receptors so
here on the left is is the virus so they
bind the virus at low temperature so it
stays on the surface of the cell and if
you stain for the virus you see there's
green all over the top of the cell so
all the virus particles are bound all
over the top of the cell now what is it
binding to its binding to DAF so here on
the right is a staining for DAF which is
one of the two receptors for
coxsackievirus so Coxsackie is binding
to the surface and it is binding to DAF
now when you raise the temperature
remember at 4 degrees viruses remain
bound to the surface when you raise the
temperature you start the infection the
viruses start to move into the cell and
so what you see right away within 30
minutes the virus in green heater has
all moved to the junctions between cells
so these are individuals
cells and that's where death is is as
well as I'm sorry
and and Daffy has also real oka lized in
these images as well so remember that
was originally spread out over the top
now it's real oka lysing to the
Junction's now if you keep going in the
infection the virus moves into the cell
now it's around the nucleus here the
nuclei here and it's beginning to
replicate and that's as far as we need
to take it there now if you look at car
to start with car is in red car is
always at the junctions remember this is
a protein stuck in the junctions between
cells it's not on the apical surface and
it stays there throughout infection and
you can see here we're staining just for
car and the cool thing here is that
eventually Daffy real oak eliza's to be
where car is and in this third column
here is the merge of the green and the
red colors you see it's yellow and that
just tells you that Daffy and car are
now in the same place on the south so
what seems to be happening here is the
virus binds to Daffy Daffy free
localizes to where car is and then the
virus can bind also car to get into
cells so that's for this virus that's
why it needs to receptors so let's show
that in a schematic so Coxsackie is
binding Daffy which is on the apical
surface of the cell so this is an
accessible receptor but apparently it's
not enough to get the virus into cells
otherwise the virus would enter at the
top
this virus requires car which is stuck
in here in the tight junctions between
cells so the virus binds Daffy and it
moves to the junction and then
eventually are now the neat thing in
addition did you have a question yeah
yeah
it seems to be staying on the surface
but that movement requires some
rearrangement of the act and
microfilaments beneath the surface and
so what happens here The Binding of the
virus to DAF actually triggers a signal
transduction Network and that loosens up
the microfilaments so that the receptor
can move along to the tight junctions so
the binding to DAF not only allows it to
move but it it loosens up the cell
surface so it can move okay so that's
just an example of why a virus would
need to receptors because the entry
receptor which is this one car that's
the one that endocytosis that's in the
tight Junction so the virus binds to a
different receptor on the surface moves
to the car receptor and then gets in
okay alright there is also another
example of entry that I wanted to tell
you about and this is for real viruses
these are these RNA viruses that have
two concentric icosahedron shells that
make up the capsid so just think of an
icosahedral shout or two of them an
outer one and an inner one and this is
actually a virus we'll talk about today
with respect to RNA synthesis this virus
is taken up by endocytosis standard
procedure we've talked about and this
that the endosome eventually fuse with
lysosomes and you know lysosomes are
full of protease ha's these protease is
in the lysosome take off the outer
capsid the outer icosahedral shell and
then that product is called is vp
infectious sub Moreau particle that then
gets out of the lysosomes / endosome and
then ends up in the cytoplasm as what's
known as a core so the core is simply
the inner icosahedral shell the outer
one is stripped off in the endosome and
you'll see later on today that this is
what then starts to produce viral RNA so
this is why we have two shells on these
viruses the first one protects the virus
as it moves around outside of cells it
stripped off during endocytosis so the
virus has evolved to take advantage of
endocytosis all those enzymes and the
lysosomes come in and take off the
capsid and then that produces a particle
that can push its way out of the
endosome because it's very hydrophobic
so we've talked about last time many
different ways that a virus can get from
the cell surface along microtubules
to near the nucleus if it needs be now
let's talk about that final step many
viruses have to get their genetic
material into the nucleus in particular
most DNA viruses have to get their
genomes in the nucleus because they're
using the enzymes of the host cell and
those are in the nucleus a few RNA
viruses also have to get there as well
so let's see how that happens there are
four different mechanisms shown here for
how you can get viral nucleic acids into
the nucleus the first one we've seen
already is influenza virus this is one
of the few RNA viruses that has to get
its nucleic acid in the nucleus it
doesn't use any enzymes there from the
cell but it uses other precursors that
we'll talk about when the virus is
uncoded from the endosome all the
ribonucleic acids bound to proteins are
released and those are quite small those
are these chain-like molecules here
these are basically helical structures
RNA plus protein just think of those
magnetic beads that we wrapped around
into a helix that's what those are and
those just can pop through the nuclear
pore you know the nucleus has these big
pore structures in them that actively
transport material into the nutrient
nucleus and you proteins in general need
to have specific signals for that and in
fact the influenza RMPs
ribonucleoproteins we call them can do
that so that's one mechanism you're
small enough to fit through some of the
larger DNA viruses can't get through
these nuclear pores they're physically
too big so there are two strategies here
for getting nucleic acids and herpes
viruses dock on to the poor the intact
virion the capsid docks on the poor
and the nucleic acid which is a
double-stranded DNA goes through that
portal
remember the portal on the capsid which
we looked at a few lectures ago allows
the DNA to get out into the nucleus
other viruses like adenovirus is still
too big to get into the pore they they
start to disassemble in the endosome and
by the time they reach the nuclear pore
they dock onto it there in a largely
disassembled State and we'll see in a
moment that disassembly goes on a bit
further at the nuclear pore and then the
nucleic acid can go in and then there's
some very small viruses like the parvo
viruses that are single-stranded DNA
containing viruses these actually small
enough to fit through the nuclear pore
so they move through and get rid of the
nucleic acid there all right so for
general strategies for how you can cross
the nuclear membrane and the last
example is adenovirus which I told you
docks in a partially disassembled form
onto the nuclear pore so here is the
nucleus here is cytoplasm would be up
here and there is a nuclear pore
adenoviruses partially disassembled it's
come out of the endosome it's moved to a
nuclear pore and now it's sitting on the
nuclear pore and in the nucleus as you
know there are histones these are these
oval shape proteins here and these
actually go through the pore out of the
pore and contact the capsid and they
bind to the exon protein which is one of
the capsid proteins and they start to
disassemble it and then they're imported
back into the nucleus the histones bound
to these capsid proteins and that
further disassembles the capsid so an
essential nuclear component of histone
actually participates in the disassembly
so here we showed capsid disassembly
mediated by the histone moving back in
and then finally the DNA is in the
capsid what's left of the capsid so this
the blue molecule with the orange dots
the orange dots is a viral protein
called protein 7 and that protein has a
nuclear localization signal on it and
that's what you need to get into the
nucleus using the important
scenery so that's how the DNA gets in
the import machinery binds these
proteins which are bound to DNA and
pulls the genome into the nucleus okay
so that's one detailed example of how a
virus moves its nucleic acid into the
nucleus now for the next two lectures
we're going to talk about the nucleic
acid synthesis that happens when these
viruses on code so we've talked about
how both DNA and RNA viruses put their
nucleic acid genomes in different parts
of the cell today we're going to focus
on RNA synthesis and just a little bit
of history so you know when when things
happened I think we mentioned already in
1935 tobacco mosaic virus was
crystallized the first crystals of the
virus to be made a year later he showed
that those crystals have about 5% RNA in
them the rest was protein he actually
thought the protein was more important
he was wrong but he did show that there
was RNA in these viruses in 1944 you
remember there the Avery a tile
experiment showing that DNA's genetic
material bacteria the hershey-chase
experiment doing the same thing in 52
for bacteria phages Watson and Crick's
structure of DNA solved in 1953 terrific
year by the way 1956 that was shown that
tobacco mosaic virus nucleic acid is
infectious and that was the first time
it was shown that RNA could be genetic
material remember these experiments in
44 and 52 were done with DNA so no one
thought that RNA could be genetic
material by 1959 RNA was found in many
animal viruses and then in the 1960s
people started saying how does this RNA
get duplicated because as far as we know
cells cannot duplicate RNA so that's
where we start today so here is a
molecule of RNA and it's used to
illustrate us a couple of important
principles that we need to remember
first we know has to be copied end to
end without any loss you can't lose
sequences at the end otherwise
eventually you have nothing left right
that sounds trivial but it's not easy to
accomplish
and if we have to keep it in mind
furthermore we have to make viral mRNAs
that can be translated by the cell
always remember that no matter what the
virus that we're talking about you have
to be able to make mRNA so we have to do
two things with these RNA genomes we
have to replicate them completely and
make mRNA from them so here's here are
the genomes we're going to talk about
today the RNA genomes we will talk about
viruses with double-stranded RNA viruses
with negative stranded single-stranded
RNA and we will talk about viruses with
positive strand genomes how they
replicate and how they make messenger
RNA sometimes two distinct processes it
is another group of viruses here with a
plus Orion RNA genome the retroviruses
but they are so special that they get a
lecture all to themselves so we're not
going to talk about those today although
we'll mention them briefly so here is a
a seminal experiment done in I don't
know the early 60s which is using
technology that isn't really used
anymore but what was done here this was
the first identification of an RNA
polymerase an enzyme that can copy a big
viral RNA and this happens to be done
with poliovirus
and what was done was to infect cells
with the virus and then at different
times after infection you can see ours
here only six hours is pretty quick
we're looking at virus production here
on the right plaque forming units per
mil and that's the dotted line so this
is a wonderful one-step growth curve you
can see the little eclipses period and
then production of virus eventually
plateauing and then on the left they're
measuring RNA polymerase activity and
what they did in this experiment they
would at each time after infection take
the cells and crack them open with a
detergent and then add a nucleoside
triphosphate which had a label probably
I would guess 1960s it was probably
tritium or C 14 doesn't really matter
but it was a radioactive isotope
and then they would ask is there any of
that isotope incorporated into big RNA
molecules and you can see that in fact
starting at about two hours after
infection you do see big RNAs made in
the cell so this is the first example of
RNA polymerase activity in cells so
that's an experiment where you take a
cell extract and you incubate it with a
labeled precursor at NTP ATP UTP c TP or
GTP doesn't really matter and you
measure the incorporation into the k ik
acid what was also found very early on
was that this synthesis that we've just
measured with radioactivity is resistant
to actinomycin D say a compound
extracted from fungi does anyone know
what maxinemize indeed does it inhibits
DNA dependent RNA synthesis so in fact
if some of the early ideas were that
these viruses copied their RNA into DNA
and that was copied then from DNA back
to RNA because no one could understand
how RNA could be copied to RNA so it
found that this was in fact resistant to
that drug showing that it's not a DNA
RNA step involved in the synthesis so
these experiments were done with polio
viruses and related viruses there are
plus strand RNA viruses it was then the
same experiments were done with minus
strand viruses the difference here which
is really important is that for
poliovirus the polymerase is found only
in infected cells it's not in the virus
particle itself it's not in the virion
for negative strand viruses which were
then studied in the same way they could
find the polymerase and infected cells
but they could also find it in the
virion
and that's of course because the
negative strand virus is when that RNA
gets into the cell this nothing can be
done with it the cell can't translate it
because it's a negative strand so those
viruses have to bring in an enzyme into
the cell okay that's a really important
concept so you have to remember that
fundamental difference between plus and
minus strand viruses eventually over the
years
it got to be there's new viruses were
discovered you could just look at the
sequence of what you thought might be a
polymerase and you could identify it by
sequence signatures so there is one trio
of amino acids glycine ASP ass which is
a signature for certain kinds of RNA
polymerases and then you could say AHA
this is the RNA polymerase and then
express it and show that it has the
right activity and now we have crystal
structures of many RNA polymerases which
show how they work so some terminology
replicase is the enzyme that copies RNA
to produce genomes the transcriptase is
the enzyme that produces mRNA typically
we say transcription is copying DNA into
RNA so this is these two are a little
confusing because for RNA viruses that
make mRNA from RNA template it's not
really a transcriptase but it's called
that anyway a promoter is a sequence
that controls the transcription of DNA
templates that is the making of RNA from
DNA and you'll hear more about that next
Wednesday and the nature of the RNA
template remember RNA genomes - strand
RNA genomes are in the virion coated
with protein remember they're wrapped up
in those helical structures and they're
ready to begin RNA synthesis as soon as
they get in the cell again negative
strand genomes have to come into a cell
with an enzyme ready to copy that in
some way otherwise the infection won't
work plus strand genomes are ready to go
they're typically naked in the virion
they don't have any proteins attached to
them and they can be translated upon
entry there's one exception and that's
that unusual family the retroviruses
that we'll talk about separately they
have plus stranded RNA to the genomes
and their particles but they are not
translated upon entry into the cell so
unfortunately that's a one exception
you're gonna have to remember we'll see
what happens to them later
double-stranded RNA genomes remember you
can't translate them the mRNA can't be
accessed by the ribosomes so they have
to be copied into mRNA and that is done
by the virus polymerase because again
the cell cannot copy these viral RNAs so
with the exception of retroviruses you
can almost predict all these steps that
have to happen upon infection now the
negative strand genomes that are bound
to proteins we have talked about before
in terms of helical structures but just
to reiterate that
here's vesicular stomatitis virus this
is the nucleo capsid which is simply the
RNA wrapped up in that one protein the N
protein nucleo capsid protein repeated
many times and that's the magnate thing
I showed you the other day so the RNA
isn't here in green and these are the
proteins this virus happens to be also
wrapped in an envelope so all the animal
viruses that have helical symmetry in
their genomes are also wrapped in
membranes the plant viruses are not
always member tobacco mosaic virus is
just a naked helical nucleocapsid and
this is just a molecular view of this
interaction here's a short piece of vsv
RNA and it's bound to the nuclear capsid
protein here's a monomer and you can see
how multiples interact both with each
other and with the viral RNA so for the
negative strand viruses again the RNA
comes encoded with these proteins and
also with other proteins that are
enzymes to copy those genomes now RNA
can have a lot of secondary and tertiary
structures and here's an illustration of
some of them you can have stems and stem
loops
formed by base pairing among
complementary regions and they can be
very simple like this one or they can
have they can be complex with multi
branch loops interior loops bulges and
hairpin loops and so forth there's also
a structure called a pseudo not because
it looks like a knot as you would tie in
a string but it isn't and that is
happening when you have a stem loop
where the loop base is base pair with
bases downstream of the stem blue
so what happens is these can base-pair
they form something like this which in
reality actually twists and if you look
at the structure the three-dimensional
structures of these which have been
solved they looked exactly like knots
we're going to encounter these in some
viral genomes and that's why I'm telling
you about them now in principle viral
RNAs can look very complicated with lots
of secondary structures remember they're
not just lines on the page we draw them
that way for simplicity so we can
explain things but they probably look
like this this RNA which is epic or no
virus RNA is probably almost all
secondary structure that is base paired
regions with large loops and there's
probably very little single stranded
structure present ok the rules for RNA
synthesis first of all it it initiates
and terminates at very specific sites on
the template sometimes the RNA
polymerase which we call RNA P may
initiate synthesis de novo that means
without a primer de novo simply means
without a primer and cellular DNA
dependent RNA polymerases work that way
those are the enzymes that make mRNA
from DNA they don't need a primer some
RNA polymerase is a viruses don't and
some do there's no way to really make
any rules for that it just can vary
depending on the virus sometimes we need
other viral and cell proteins to make
mRNA so the polymerase itself isn't
needed isn't the only thing necessary
and finally RNA is synthesized on a
template of course you copy a template
by stepwise incorporation of ntps
and we always elongate in a 5 to 3 prime
direction very similar to the rules for
making DNA
so that's templated synthesis there are
also some examples where RNA is made
without a template but for only very
short regions and we'll talk about those
so here are some examples of initiation
here's de novo initiation you have a 3
prime end of an RNA remember the RNAs
are always some kind of green color and
here's an example of how you put the
first complementary base down at the 3
prime end the polymerase does this
doesn't need a primer it's just sitting
down in the template and putting a base
and sometimes those are just single
bases that are added sometimes they're
capped here
it doesn't really matter and here are
two examples of primer dependent
initiation remember we said some of the
polymerases need a primer some of them
don't here are two examples of priming
here the protein the primer is a short
piece of nucleic acid actually linked to
a protein this is called protein linked
priming and we'll see an example of that
for polio
sometimes the prompt that primers are
capped the cap is of course our
structures on the five prime ends of
cellular messenger RNAs these are
important for translation but sometimes
they are used for priming viral RNA
polymerases this all of you should know
having taken some kind of biology or
biochemistry class that's the way that
nucleic acids are synthesized again
there's a template for the most part
we're going to talk about using a
template here a primer hybridizes to the
template and then new bases are added by
the polymerase to the three prime end so
the template is read in a three to five
prime direction but the product is
synthesized in a 5 to 3 prime direction
so those are universal rules for nucleic
acid synthesis and this just shows you a
typical template primer arrangement this
happens to be DNA you can tell because
there's a tea instead of you here and we
have 2 3 bases paired here and you can
see that the addition of a new
triphosphate at NTP
to the growing chain comes about by a
series of essentially nucleophilic
attacks on the phosphates and oxygens
that constitute this we don't need to
know this for this course this is
something you should know already but it
happens exactly the same way for viruses
as it does for cellular enzymes now all
of the representatives of the different
kinds of nucleic acid polymer aces have
been studied a lot who we have RNA
dependent RNA polymerases we have RNA
dependent DNA polymerases we have DNA
DNA
and then we have DNA polymerases that
make mRNA so there are four classes that
we know about
we've got sequences of all these we have
crystal structures of all of them and
this is the way the sequences of these
polymerase is line up you can see they
have a lot of conserved regions those
are the green parts here and there are
also unique portions to each polymerase
as well and a couple of points I want to
make out all the polymerase is of plus
strand RNA viruses they have AG lie ASP
ASP that's that GD D sequence I talked
about earlier which is present here in
this part of the polymerase so that's
right there the segmented minus strand
enzymes haven't asked ASP there as well
and in non-segmented minus strand
polymer aces there's a gly ASP acid
these are not these are not things I
would ask you to recall but I just want
to tell you this because it's a way of
identifying particular polymerases so
there are some conserved regions but
there are also lots of unique region
they probably all evolved from a common
precursor and then involved two
different kinds of polymerization so
here's the structure of the RNA
dependent RNA polymerase of polio
viruses these all resemble a hand with a
thumb domain a fingers domain and a palm
and the palm is typically the active
site of the enzyme and here in the
middle of this is the active site and in
fact there these are two very important
side chains here that were involved in
polymerization of nucleic acid so we're
not quite sure how the nucleic acid
moves in these but one model is that the
template moves through the bottom here
passes the active site where then the
synthesis is done and then the product
moves out of the top of the enzyme so
the active site is here then everything
else is involved in template
discrimination and adding specific kinds
of triphosphates this is an interesting
part of the enzyme this is the polio RNA
polymerase and we're looking very close
in at the active site and this is
probably the interaction here's the
active site of the enzyme and
they're a variety of side chains shown
here and this is a triphosphate you can
see the three phosphates here that's
coming into the active site it's about
to be added to the next to the next base
in the growing chain and this base is an
aspect to 38 you can see it's hydrogen
bonding here that is probably how these
enzymes discriminate DNA from RNA so you
if this is an RNA polymerase you're
gonna copy an RNA template you only want
to add Ryba nucleoside triphosphates
here and of course they have a hydroxyl
group here in this position and they
will but base pair their hydrogen bond
with this aspect 238 if a dntp moved in
here it wouldn't form this base pair and
it would be rejected so this is a very
nice way how these enzymes can
discriminate between dntps and ntps of
course which are all floating around in
the cell at the same time and here's a
model of how the primer and template fit
into this active site so here is one of
these RNA polymerase is we've actually
cut away the front and here's the active
site up here these red regions and
there's usually a metal amount of
magnesium or manganese that's absolutely
required for catalysis that's that
little ball right there the template is
in yellow and the primer is in green and
this is the next triphosphate about to
be added to this chain sitting in the
active site so it gives you some idea of
the architecture of this complex so
let's talk about some of the overall
processes for due to different kinds of
viruses there's are both plus strand RNA
viruses and we'll start with with the
Flavie and picornaviruses on the left
these viruses have a plus strand RNA
genome it's copied through a negative
strand intermediate which is then copied
to form plus strands it's a very simple
arrangement the minus strand has no
function other to serve as a template so
it's not translated it doesn't have
anything else to do in the cell except
be copied again to make plus strands so
the flavie's have a cap at the five
prime end of their genome and this is
basically an mrna so for these viruses
the mRNA and the gene
are exactly the same thing so when you
make a genome you're making mRNA the
corners don't have a cap up here as you
will see they have a little protein
linked to the five prime end and as
we'll see later the Alpha viruses which
are also plus strand viruses have a very
different strategy of gene expression
so the Pokorny virus is again which are
exemplified by the schema on the left of
that previous slide we've seen this
before they bind receptors on cells and
the RNA needs to get in the cytoplasm
that's as far as it has to go because
it's a plus strand RNA and it can be
translated directly so as soon as this
RNA is in the cytoplasm ribosomes
recognize it and they begin making viral
proteins this RNA comes in naked
remember it's a plus strand RNA and
because it's plus stranded it can be
immediately recognized he doesn't as I
said it is duplicated through a negative
strand intermedia and that's shown on
the right so here is the input
RNA the viral RNA in kelly green i guess
and then it becomes olive green which is
the negative strand and then it becomes
kelly again alright it so goes plus
minus and plus very simple strategy
again carried out by the viral RNA
polymerase this happens on membrane
vesicles in the cytoplasm it turns out
that all the plus strand RNA viruses do
their RNA synthesis on vesicles not just
floating around in this cell remember
the cell is a crowded place and the
likelihood that an RNA and a polymerase
and try phosphates are all going to bump
into each other is pretty low so what
these viruses do are assemble
replication complexes on vesicles as
shown here and that makes it more
efficient yes
so different mRNAs are decayed at
different rates depending on sequences
in them it's a it's a carefully
controlled process these viral RNAs are
particularly stable they've evolved to
be very stable so they're not degraded
in the cell and in fact there's so much
of them made eventually that they
overwhelm the cell and eventually the
cell mRNAs are degraded because they're
not made anymore they have a certain
half-life the viruses shut off
transcription so there's no more
competition for translation yes why do
it so why we need to make a minus strand
so it's said the way nucleic acid
replication works as you know the
nucleic acids are series of bases and to
replicate it we have to make a
complementary strand so wherever there's
an A you have to make a strand with a T
and then you make an A again so there's
no other way to to duplicate that
nucleic acid without an intermediate so
double-stranded DNA you remember each
strand is copied to make new strands but
here we only have one so we have to copy
it through an intermediate and that's
the only function for these negative
strands just serve as templates
good question when it comes in the cell
this plus strand RNA what is the first
thing that happens does it get
translated or you make a negative strand
do you know the answer you could look at
this it's okay yeah you could translate
it and why is that why does the plus
strand have to be translated and not
replicated do you know anybody do you
need the RNA polymerase because there's
no way this RNA can be copied by the
cell really important concept you put a
plus strand viral RNA in the cell can't
be copied so it has to be translated
first you can so if you just know that
cells can't copy aren't viral RNAs you
can figure out what happens when a plus
or minus strand RNA comes into a cell
because we'll see with a negative strand
RNA has to be copied first therefore it
has to bring in a polymerase with it
okay so here's the polio genome it's a
plus strand RNA comes in the cell it is
immediately translated and you get a
what is called a poly protein this is
one way of making a lot of proteins from
a single message now in eukaryotic cells
one messenger RNA one protein so viruses
have to get around that limitation in
bacteria that's not the issue you can
make one mRNA can make several proteins
but not in mammalian cells for the most
part so how does polio get around that
and the pakoras and the flavie's they
make a long protein and it's chopped up
by proteases that are embedded in the
sequence so they can make 12 proteins
from one and from one precursor in one
mRNA all right so the RNA polymerase
that is copying these genomes is
translated down here
it's called 3d PAH okay now the RNA has
sequences or structures in it that are
signals for RNA replication and here's
the RNA genome presented in a slightly
different way we have at the five prime
end a clove
we have in the middle of stem-loop and
at the 3-prime end a pseudo na and these
are all important signals for RNA
replication now think when when polio
infects a cell and the the polymerase is
made and it replicates the genome it
only copies viral RNAs it never copies
cellular mRNAs even though cellular RNAs
look pretty much like this they have
their RNA and they have a poly a
sequence at the three prime end so why
wouldn't they be copied by the viral
polymerase well in fact it's because of
these kinds of structures that say copy
only this RNA and these aren't present
in messenger RNA so they don't get
copied I'm going to show you why these
confer specificity right now now at the
five prime end of the viral RNA shown
here this little orange dot it's is a
small protein called vpg virion protein
genome linked its 22 amino acids long
here it is again in this slide and it is
covalently linked to the first base of
the genome of polio so here is the first
nucleotides of polio RNA they fold into
a cloverleaf and the first base is au
and that is linked via this
phosphodiester bond to a tyrosine on vpg
so this is a covalent likud linkage and
this is actually this protein is
actually removed that some part of the
infectious cycle which we don't have to
worry about and that's what that arrow
means this protein is actually the
primer for RNA replication so polio RNA
polymerase is a primer dependent enzyme
it can't initiate synthesis de novo and
the primer is actually this protein
linked to two nucleotides are two bases
which we will see so the primer is made
actually before RNA synthesis can begin
and the important signal in the genome
is this stem loop called cree which i
showed you on this previous slide isn't
that somewhere in the middle of the
genome it actually is in different
places in different book
of viruses that doesn't matter too much
the point is this is where the primer is
initially synthesized so what happens is
the RNA polymerase shown here binds as a
dimer to this Kree v PG comes along and
then the RNA polymerase actually copies
but to a residues which are in the loop
of this Kree sequence and that allows it
to put to use on to this V PG so this is
basically how this primer is synthesized
by the polymerase by taking v PG which
has already been made so far in viral
infection and then linking to use on to
it the user templated by this Kree loop
at the top here very interesting use of
a stem loop now somehow this primer has
to get to the three prime end of the
mRNA of the genome remember initiation
goes from the three prime end and
synthesis in a 5 to 3 prime direction so
this primer has to get to the 3 prime
and yet the Kree sequences are in the
middle of the genome so this is the
conundrum that has to be solved and we
think it's solved by circular izing the
RNA this is a hypothetical model for RNA
replication which has some very
interesting elements and the idea is
that the RNA replication complex which
is shown at the top is membrane bound
remember it occurs on the surface of
those vesicles it's held in place to the
membrane by a membrane protein of the
viral protein called 3 a B which
interacts with a cellular protein that
in turn is binding this cloverleaf and
that is what attaches the RNA complex to
the membrane this is the viral RNA the
cloverleaf is at the 5 prime end and the
here is the 3 prime end of the genome
and there of course there is a poly a
sequence this is a messenger RNA of
course as well as a viral RNA and this
RNA becomes circularized or maybe I
should say the ends are brought together
because the poly a sequence is bound by
a cell protein called poly a binding
protein P ABP which in turn will bind
the cloverleaf and all the proteins that
are associated with it so we have the 5
and the 3 prime ends of the R
are brought together and that that's how
initiation begins because here at the
5-prime end is the RNA polymerase and
once the three prime end is brought to
it it can start copying that RNA and
making a negative strand and it uses the
primer we don't know how this v PG pu pu
gets over here to initiate priming but
somehow it does you can see there's a
magical leap from here to here and then
that initiates synthesis on the three
prime end and then you get elongation
and eventually the synthesis of a
negative strand so here's our original
plus strand and now we have the negative
strand and then of course it's copied
the negative strand is copied again by a
similar mechanism to make more plus
strands so these are very unusual
mechanisms that are be lying the
simplicity of this kind of scheme here
plus minus plus now on the right is the
scheme for alpha viruses these are also
plus strand viruses but they do
something different they have a plus
strand RNA and so when they come in the
cell the first thing that happens is
that they are translated and you make a
negative strand compliment to make more
genomes but there is also the production
of a small mRNA in the life cycle of
these viruses that RNA is made from this
negative strand intermediate we don't
know why this has to be done this way it
works and it's evolved to be this way
this virus could just as easily have a
scheme like this but it doesn't it
translates part of this plus strand and
it doesn't translate the rest and the
rest of it has to be accessed by what we
call a sub genomic mRNA so this is the
life cycle for these viruses we've
talked about how some of these viruses
enter cells before through endocytosis
so basically this recapitulates what
I've told you the viral RNA gets put
into the cytoplasm the first half of it
is translated and the protein that is
made is actually the viral RNA
polymerase that makes perfect sense
because that then goes on and copies
that input RNA it makes full-length
negative strands and more plus strands
but it also
these negative strands and makes a small
mRNA the sub genomic mRNA so that the
second half of the genome can be
accessed because this translation step
here is only translating the first half
of the genome by making this sub genomic
mRNA you get the second half produced
and eventually all the proteins made go
for the production of new virus
particles so it's just a twist on
getting your information in your genome
decoded and again the problem is if you
have only one mRNA you can either make a
poly protein or maybe you can make small
RNAs from it so this virus takes both
strategies it makes a poly protein here
but it also makes a small sub genomic
RNA so here is an example where that
negative strand has some function it
serves as a template for making these
mRNAs here and here's another view of
the same process just to make it clear
here's our viral RNA when it gets into
the cell it's translated but only half
of it is translated there's a stop codon
here that's the red dot so you get these
proteins produced which are the RNA
polymerase once they're made they can
replicate the plus into a minus strand
and so on back to plus and minus but
they can also this polymerase can also
make a sub genomic mRNA from the latter
half of the negative strand and that can
be translated then to access these
proteins and again I don't know why it
works this way you would think that it
could just you could get rid of this
stop codon and just keep translating and
process it like polio but it doesn't
work that way
this is evolved so apparently it is
successful now among the minus strand
RNA viruses there are both uni molecular
genomes that is an RNA in one piece and
segmented genomes RNAs and pieces we're
going to talk about both of these the
negative strand virus is of course
here's the genome of the negative strand
virus it's negative stranded when it
gets in the cell can't be recognized by
the translation apparatus so it has to
come in the cell with an RNA polymerase
and that RNA polymerase has to make mRNA
as the first step otherwise you can't
make proteins yeah it comes in with
proteins
nothing can read it exactly whenever you
have a minus strand RNA coming into the
cell it always has to come in with
proteins multiple proteins that can copy
it and make message and that's what you
see here this is making messenger RNA
from this minus strand so that goes for
the Uni molecular aren't viruses or the
segmented viruses you always have to
make a messenger RNA first once you make
a message then you can make proteins and
then you can replicate your genomes
which is what's happening here you make
a plus strand intermediate which you
throw away after you've copied it into
negative strands so it's the opposite of
the plus strand viruses for both uni
molecular and segmented you do mRNA
synthesis first and then you do genome
replication so let's look at this
process and a little detail here is our
bullet-shaped virus vesicular stomatitis
virus again entry via endocytosis the
genome ends up in the cytoplasm
it's complexed with proteins remember
it's not naked
it can't be translated it's a negative
strand RNA so that has to be made into
mRNAs that's step 3 here we have
individual mRNAs which are then
translated into proteins and one of
these proteins goes on and replicates
the RNA and makes more mRNAs alright so
again to translate you have to make a
messenger RNA and that all these
proteins that are bound to the RNA have
a role in that they constitute not only
the repetitive nuclear protein that
makes the helix but also the RNA
polymerase is in there as well and
here's another look at that same virus
vesicular stomatitis virus here's the
genome a single long negative strand RNA
that's why we call it uni molecular and
when this comes into a cell it's
negative stranded it can't be translated
it has to be copied into messenger rnas
and that's what these little guys are
down here these are 1 2 3 4 5
mrnas they're all capped they all have a
poly a tail they look just like cellular
mRNAs and the cell ribosomes just bind
to them and translate and you get all
the viral proteins make mRNAs first step
and then one of the proteins made is the
RNA polymerase which is this the L
protein and that can then take this this
negative strand genome and make a plus
strand it has to make a full-length plus
strand remember from end to end it has
to copy the whole thing you can't just
make them mRNA you'll never get the
virus back from those right because
you're missing sequences in between them
that's why you have to make a plus
strand intermediate so here's how that
works
you have our viral RNA a polymerase goes
on the three prime end that comes in
with the virus that makes these mRNA s
here and then eventually when you get
some proteins made the process switches
to replication which is to make a plus
strand and then a minus strand so there
is a switch late in the replication
cycle from making messages to making
full-length plus and then minus strands
because eventually you have to make new
virions and to do that you need more
minus strands right the organization of
this virus goes back to that problem
that we had before you have one mRNA or
one RNA and you have to make multiple
proteins from it so this virus's
approach is to make five sub genomic
mRNAs remember the pakoras make a big
protein and cleave it these viruses make
five mRNAs they could make a poly
protein from A plus strand and
intermediate but they don't the way this
synthesis works here's again our
negative strand RNA which comes in the
polymerase binds is bound at the three
prime end as it comes in with the
particle it makes the first messenger
RNA then it stops and that mRNA comes
off it's capped and polyadenylated
and then the preliminary stays on the
genome and makes the second messenger
RNA then it stops and that RNA is
released and it keeps going down the
line so there's this polar progression
along the mRNA and in between each gene
there's this IG and intergenic sequence
there is a stretch of you molecules in
there when the polymerase sees that it
starts to put A's in and it keeps going
until there are one or two hundred days
and that's a poly a tail so from a
little sequence of seven use it makes a
full-blown poly a tail at the end of
each messenger RNA and then it stops
making poly a it's it slips down a
little and then initiates the next mRNA
very interesting scheme now let's talk
about a segmented or negative strand RNA
virus influenza virus this looks
horribly complicated right and you're
wondering do I have to memorize this and
no not really but I just want to show
some aspects of what we're talking about
here these viruses are negative stranded
they have segmented genomes the genomes
released by fusion of the endosome with
the viral membrane so now we have the
rnas and the cytoplasm this is a
negative stranded RNA are these RNAs
naked no they have proteins on them to
copy them into 2 plus strands they go
into the nuclear pore this is one RNA
virus that needs the nucleus go into the
nuclear pore and then the each strand
each negative strand is copied to form a
messenger RNA by the RNA polymerases
that come in with each segment so these
are these mRNAs shown here those get
exported into the cytoplasm to make
viral proteins eventually you also have
to make more genomes these guys here so
you take your incoming negative strands
you make a full-length plus strand and
from those you make more genomes and
those go on to form new virus particles
now there's one aspect of this process
that I want to tell you in some detail
and that is the priming of the mRNA
synthesis in other words the incoming
minus strand you make an mRNA from it
that enzyme that comes in with the
segment is primer dependent the primer
that is used comes from cellular mRNAs
so here is an overall view of that again
for flu we have eight RNA segments
they're all negative stranded when those
get in the nucleus you make mRNA s from
each of them and those are translated
into protein that process from negative
strand to mRNA requires a primer and
here is the primer that is used for that
it's right here it is a small piece of
mRNA from the host cell so this is the
viral RNA comes in covered with proteins
and from it the first thing that has to
happen is we want to make mRNA the RNA
polymerase that's embedded with this
segment needs a primer and so what it
does is it grabs a host mRNA that
happens to be near it and it cuts its 5
prime end off and it takes the cap plus
about 10 or 12 bases from that mRNA and
it uses that as a primer and that's why
we think these viruses have to replicate
in the nucleus because they need newly
synthesized mRNAs produced in the
nucleus so this primer which ends up at
the 5 prime end of every viral messenger
RNA is host cell derived and it can come
from any messenger RNA not any one in
particular in fact if you if you extract
influenza viral mRNA s from infected
cells the first 12 bases will be random
it will be derived from every possible
mRNA in the cell so that mRNA has a cell
derived primer at the 5 prime end and it
also stops at about 20 nucleotides short
of the template because then it's
polyadenylated so this mRNA would not be
good for making more viruses because
it's lacking sequence down here at the 3
prime end alright remember I said the a
requirement for genome replication is
that you have to copy the genome from
end to end and this is not doing that
you're actually ending up short so
that's why we need another replication
step we have to copy this negative
strand into a full-length plus strand
and then copy it into a full-length
minus strand and that is going to be our
genome RNA so the details here are not
important for you to know that are well
these proteins he
here the important thing is is that the
MRNA isn't a full-length copy and that's
why you need to make a plus strand yeah
exactly
yes to make this RNA from the negative
strand you do not need a primer it's
unprimed as you see here it it's very
interesting actually because the same
that the enzyme is slightly different so
in one case to make mRNA its primer
dependent and in the other case its
primer independent and here's some
detail on that very interesting process
we call it cap snatching stealing of the
cap from the host mRNA to Prime mRNA
synthesis so here is the viral RNA it's
the three prime end here is a host mrna
there's a cap structure and then some
bases and as I told you the viral RNA
polymerase actually has an endonuclease
activity so it Cleaves host mRNAs about
here 13 bases on this one and then the
primer that results is used to initiate
synthesis of the messenger RNA which you
can see here so here's the mRNA that's
made this is the negative strand
template and they all have this bit of
sequence from host mRNAs so that's
probably one of the reasons why you need
to be in the nucleus for these viruses
now all of these mRNAs are
polyadenylated and remember I told you
they end up about 20 bases short of the
template and so this is a model of why
that happens it's actually very clever
now normally you imagine a template in a
polymerase is moving along the template
and copying it and a nucleic acid is
being made but here we think the
template is being pulled through the
polymerase somehow so this limb race
consists of three subunits and here is
the viral RNA here in the olive green
it's negative stranded all right it's
bound here the 5 prime end to the
polymerase the this is a polymerase
making a plus strand mRNA so here's the
active site of the polymerase it's being
elongated and imagine that
three prime end is being pulled through
this complex so as this moves past the
active site you elongate the mRNA
product you're pulling it through but
eventually when you run out of loop here
it stops and there's still about 20
bases left here but you can't copy them
because you can't move well what you're
stuck at is a stretch of use so what do
you think happens the enzyme just keeps
making A's over and over again until it
gets tired and says that's it I've had
it and it gets the product gets released
and you have a poly ventilated mRNA
which lacks about 20 bases from the
3-prime and so that that may explain why
we're missing those 20 bases because you
have this mechanism of pulling the
template through okay double-stranded
RNA viruses do something different
because remember the double-stranded RNA
even though it has a plus strand it
can't be accessed by ribosomes so what
happens is this double strand is a
template for the synthesis of a plus
strand mRNA so the viral the virus has
to bring in an RNA polymerase with it so
you may say well because it has a plus
strand couldn't that be used for
translation no it can't because it's
double stranded and there's no way to
nature it so instead the virus brings in
a polymerase with the particle and then
copies the negative strand of that
duplex to make a plus strand mRNA for
translation and it actually makes double
strands from a subset of those as well
so these are both plus strand mRNAs made
from the minus strand one is used for
translation and one is simply copied to
make a negative strand now we have our
double stranded RNA it's just what we
started with okay and this is again by
an enzyme that the virus brings in with
it so these are the real viruses and
they have segmented double stranded RNA
genomes remember these are the viruses
that are the double shell they come in
through the endo siddik pathway the
outer shell is stripped off and then the
core particle goes into the cytoplasm
there are a number of double stranded
RNA particles 3 6 9 10 for the
real virus and from each of those and
mRNA is made shown here and from those
proteins are made again this is not
translated the genomic double strand RNA
is not translated it's copied to form a
plus strand mRNA yes
I don't know if it has to actually be
pulled apart it could you could just
make a bubble and move it along the
duplex yeah so it doesn't necessarily as
dr. Silverstein will show you for DNA
you don't have to pull the strands you
don't have to know you can just make a
little des natured bubble and the
polymerase can can copy that
yeah it's really very nice so here is a
scheme of the replication of these
viruses and what I want to show you here
is the viruses just focus here the virus
is taken up by endocytosis that outer
capsid is stripped off and the particle
gets out of the endosome and now we have
this inner shell particle sitting in the
cytoplasm and that still has all the
double-stranded RNAs in it it has the
enzymes to copy them and that that
particle just sits there in the and the
mRNAs come out of the the each to a
fivefold axis of symmetry there are 12
of those remember it's icosahedron and
there's a little channel at each
fivefold and you can see on this picture
these little squiggly green guys coming
out here those are mRNAs they're made
inside the particle and shot outside and
then they're translated in the cytosol
and they give rise to new particles
eventually we'll talk about that later
but all the mRNA synthesis takes place
inside the particle so it never really
completely on coats and that's one of
the reasons why I said initially that
some viruses are active containers that
it doesn't they don't discharge all of
their RNA or nucleic acid into the
cytoplasm here's the reason for that
okay the mRNAs again copied off the
double-stranded RNA template by a
polymerase that's in the particle and
the mRNAs are extruded through the
turret now there is a very nice
structure of this process which I want
to show you these are cryo-electron
microscopy and this family and these
were in the process of making mRNA when
the cryo e/m was done so here's the
particle here you can see these little
purple things sticking out here that's
the that's the mRNA coming out right
here
so right there so this is one of the 12
turrets at each fivefold axis of
symmetry and I told you we think the RNA
out of here as its made in the interior
and this is actually a model for how
that might happen the only density they
got in these cryo Am's was this little
bit here and they they filled in the
rest this is the RNA the mRNA coming out
of this portal if you will It's Made
inside the particle and comes out very
neat now an important thing that you
should know is that RNA synthesis is an
important source of diversity all of
these polymerases that we've talked
about today they make errors well in
fact every nucleic acid polymerase makes
errors and the RNA polymerases make one
mistake out of every thousand or 10,000
bases that they make so you some of
these viral genomes are ten thousand
bases long so every time they're copied
there's a mistake made the wrong base is
put in despite those wonderful
polymerases you know that sometimes they
see a there's an a there and they put
something else instead of a you now RNA
polymerase is don't have proofreading
like DNA polymerases do they can say the
wrong base here take it out and fix it
but RNA polymerase is don't do that so
they have the very high error rate but
in many ways that's good because it
contributes to the diversity of RNA
viruses and in fact we're gonna use
we're going to talk about that much more
later on in this course because it is an
important source of new viruses and
viral evolution so just remember that
this RNA synthesis is really important
for diversity of RNA viruses and I
promised I'd tell you about the non
templated RNA synthesis that occurs for
some viruses all that means is that
templated RNA synthesis you have an RNA
template and the polymerase copies every
base it makes a faithful copy nan
template it is when it puts something in
that isn't in the template and so this
happens with measles and mumps virus
these are viruses with single negative
strand RNA genomes and from them the the
individual mRNAs are made when these
viruses come into salad remember there's
a polymerase in the particle that does
that all those mRNAs are faithful copies
of the template
except here in this P mRNA it's a second
mRNA made from the end now in the end a
certain fraction of the time the
polymerase inserts an extra base that's
not in the template and we're not sure
why but there's some kind of an RNA
structure in this region we think the
polymerase bumps into it and makes a
mistake adds an extra base but in fact
it's beneficial for the virus because
not all not all the messenger RNAs have
this extra base but the ones that do can
make a different protein so here's a
schematic of this here is the minus
strand RNA template so normally it's
copied to make a faithful mRNA copy but
some of the time then this extra G is
inserted here so again the polymerase
makes a mistake it makes a G here but
there's no G there's no seat templated
by that G on the negative strand
template and then it resumes copying
downstream the net result is you have
one extra G in this mRNA that's not in
the template so that's what we mean by
non templated mRNA synthesis so the
result is that normally you have one
protein made from this normal mRNA which
is shown here but if you add an extra G
the the reading frame changes downstream
of the gene you get a different sequence
so this protein has a different C
terminal sequence from this one so you
can make two different proteins and in
fact these viruses depend on doing this
if you take this away they're not happy
so it's another way of getting more
genetic information out of a single mRNA
you can see a number of tricks now that
have emerged to do this yes
what you asked it's not deliberate yeah
it appears to be because it's been
evolutionarily conserved it's not taken
away it makes the protein that has a
specific function yeah so the the
replication scheme of this virus has
evolved to incorporate this
you